ROBERT KUBIS: In this
episode of "Things
I Learned About
Cloud Spanner," we
look at choosing the
right primary keys
to help detect and avoid
traffic jams during data load.
Will we be able to clear
the data highway congestion?
Stay tuned to find out.
So a while ago, my
friend Anna approached
me asking if I could give her
advice on a database migration.
Her online shop,
Pile of Gadgets,
selling toys like the Cloud
Spanner fidget spinner,
has grown tremendously,
and she was
worried to have the
business running
on the back of a traditional
relational database.
After watching the
first episode of "Things
I Learned About Cloud
Spanner," her team
decided to explore and
evaluate this new SQL database.
They started from a recent
backup of the database
where all the data was
exported through CSV files
and uploaded to
Google Cloud Storage.
They then wrote a
little loader program
that was reading the files,
processing them, and writing
the data to Cloud Spanner.
So far so good.
Having the files in
Google Cloud Storage
and processing them
from a GCE instance,
Cloud Storage or Cloud Spanner
instance, is actually great.
This way you don't need to worry
about network capacity or added
latencies being an issue
during your data load.
However, while running
their first data loads
on a regional instance, there
was some disappointment.
They only saw a 35% utilization
of their three node instance.
Trying to increase the
utilization by scaling
out the loaders
didn't help either.
Now, that was interesting.
It looked like their load is
hot spotting on only one node.
Three nodes, 35%--
you do the math.
To verify the assumption,
they scaled the instance
to five nodes and saw that
the utilization dropped
to around 20%, while the number
of transactions and throughputs
stayed the same.
And that was a clear indicator
that only one of the nodes
was doing work here
while the others--
[SPINNING]
At this point, we needed
to dig a little deeper
and understand how
Cloud Spanner organizes
data to scale your workloads.
Reading the
documentation, you find
that Cloud Spanner
organizes rows
in a table lexicographically,
or for the mere mortals like me,
alphabetically by
the primary key.
Then driven by the size of
your tables and load patterns,
your data gets divided into
chunks, so-called splits.
These splits are
distinct ranges of rows
based on your primary key.
To efficiently scale out
all your reads and writes,
each individual
split can move freely
between the available compute
nodes while making sure there
is always--
and I mean always--
only one node that controls
the writes to a split.
Now, that's where
it gets tricky.
If you write to a table with
monotonically increasing
or decreasing primary key
values, like 123 or ABC,
all your requests get sent
to one split, the first
or the last in your keyspace.
And if you load
many rows at once,
you eventually
exhaust the resources
of your responsible
node for that one split.
Packed with this newly
gained knowledge,
we went back and took a
look at the schema and data
from Pile of Gadget.
It turned out that
the application uses
an outer incremented integer
for some of their primary keys,
and the data was exported
in that order, which
is creating a
hotspot during load
by adding new rows
always to the last split.
To resolve this,
they needed to modify
the schema, such as introducing
a distribution key that you
prefix in your primary key, or
using a well distributed hash
function to hash
your existing key,
or introduce an
entirely new primary key
that is well disputed.
With future scalability
requirements in mind,
they opted to
generate a new UUID
version for base primary key
and kept the old ID around
for potential legacy purposes.
After these modifications,
they ran the data loads again
and saw over time
a full utilization
of their Cloud
Spanner instance where
the throughput scaled with
the number of instance nodes.
A little side note
here, as you start
to load an empty database,
it will take some time
for the first splits to occur
and the load-based rebalancing
to kick in.
So it will take some time before
you see the full utilization
of your instance.
So now my friend's
company, Pile of Gadget,
was happy to continue
their evaluation
and see if they could improve
the load performance even
further.
Unfortunately, we
are out of time.
To find out what we did
next to maximize throughput
during load, check
out the next episode
of "Things I Learned
About Cloud Spanner."
And remember, choosing well
distributed primary keys
sets you up for scalability.
Last but not least,
for the ones that
love to dive into
source code and run
the experiments, to
learn more, check out
the links in the descriptions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]